hey guys it's kathryn newton and i am
excited to talk a little bit about my
new movie freaky
and play with my poodles while i take
some of your fan questions
let's go
this is during tail jack king ruler of
all flute and we just call him jack and
this is
rose bud tell a good boy gonna need a
big bang but we just call him buddy
this is my little lady bird keep the
madness rolling
but i just call her little because she
doesn't know her name
she pees everywhere she does whatever
she wants she's not trained at all
she eats when she wants like she's just
like a little fluff
of love
of course vince was so collaborative i
got so many ideas from him about how to
play a butcher
as well as the teenage girl milly we
talked about um
mannerisms and how millie will walk and
how the butcher would walk and we
started to imitate each other
i would look at my feet and like get
grounded and
you know when you're using like a
chainsaw and a knife and you've got
blood all over you you kind of just kind
of
you just go there i would walk around
and people would go
and they'd get scared i'm sorry did i
frighten you he's okay
i don't remember what i was saying
because i got distracted by my poodle
i have a couple options but you know my
first choice would probably be psyduck
and you know psyduck and i actually
swapped bodies in the movie so i was
sighed up for a second also there's a
fur fruit which is a poodle pokemon and
if i had to swap bodies it would
probably be with one of my poodles
probably jack because he gets the most
attention but a fur fruit that would be
my pick
i love jennifer's body i think that's an
iconic movie and i love all the
paranormal activity movies
and also the classics like halloween and
friday the 13th
they just get you in the spirit and i
love watching them with my friends and
like getting scared and actually not
watching them at all i cover my eyes the
whole time
i binge watched the marvelous miss
maisel twice
i just think it's brilliant and i think
it's the best show ever
the production is so good and then i
also rewatched entourage
while i was in quarantine see i don't
have an entourage but i have an
entourage of pools
so that counts
i think that we would have had a lot of
questions answered and i think we would
have gotten some more hallie content
which is really all i cared about
i just am sad that it got cancelled
because i loved our cast so much they
were so talented and
yes so i was really sad when it got
canceled and we all found out together
we had a zoom
and we all cried and you know they're
all my close friends now and
you know that doesn't die and the power
of the fans is strong
and so maybe if they keep asking you
know someone will
come up with a way for us to finish the
story when it got cancelled and i was on
twitter and i was looking at everything
it made me feel a lot of love to see how
many people were sad that i got
cancelled oh buddy now that's just rude
just
oh stop
i think ally is the queen hbic
stop it buddy that is inappropriate but
i don't know i think that we would have
found out who becca's baby daddy is you
have to stop
doing that buddy that is not appropriate
and i think uh we would have found out
why the kids are
in another parallel universe you know
it's just there's a lot of like
supernatural questions that i would have
liked to know
what do you think buddy what do you
think we would have found out oh well i
don't know i think we would have found
out who becca's baby daddy is oh you
want me to crack your tummy
let's just close that
oh my gosh yeah we used to have amazing
parties one
some of the parties would be at my house
and they were always the boring parties
because i made everybody go to bed at
midnight because i'm lame
and then like toby and alex fitzallen
would have like these ragers
so like things like that and they never
got to meet the foods so i'm a little
sad about that
i would have liked the cast to meet my
family that would have been the next
step in our relationship
i'm so grateful for the love that you've
given us and i'm really sorry that
we don't get to finish the story for you
but i hope that you never stop loving
the society because i won't
i was pretty starstruck by merrell it's
like not even starstruck you just kind
of feel like you're in the face of
royalty or something
so you kind of have to just bow down and
you know i'll never forget the first
table read when i saw her walk in and i
was
with teresa i was like what do i do what
do i do like and she was like just go
say hi
you always go say hi first and i thought
that was a really good piece of advice
anyway like you know when you see
somebody at a dinner or something and
you recognize them
of course you should say hi first just
break that ice anyway and of course she
gave me a big hug
when you were allowed to give people
hugs and she told me
so many nice things and so it was
everything i could have ever dreamed of
what do i smell do i stink
oh my god i stole so many pens it's not
that exciting but i'm always stealing
pens
also i got to keep a lot of the clothes
a lot of the abigail clothes like she
had these sick army track pants
i'm yes
do you have something you want to say
you just want more scratches
so i stole some clothes um from abigail
and i've actually worn them again in
other projects
loki
i don't think anybody would be surprised
by how sweet she is in real life
she's like a ray of sunshine on you know
on tv and
on instagram and she's just like that in
real life it's as
authentic as what you see and i think
that's surprising she's as sweet as my
dogs
actually they're not that sweet they
just look fluffy
i'm sorry that was rude i take it back
that's really hard to pick because she
has so many iconic movies legally blonde
one of my favorites of all time election
i've seen too many times i could go on i
mean
even just getting to be in big little
lives that's one of my favorite projects
ever
[Music]
that show changed my life i learned so
much from jensen and jared i'm so
upset that the show is over because it
always felt like home
i just kind of had this idea that i
would go back to it at some point or
like be on that show
but you know i learned a lot from jensen
especially like just from being on set
and watching
him and jared like the way they carry
themselves everyone on that set from the
transfer people to like craft service
everyone loved being there and it's
because of them like setting that tone
you know after i did my episodes the
tweets
started saying that claire needs her own
spin-off claire needs her own show
and i was like that'll never happen and
then i got the call one day that they
wanted to give claire
wayward it's the spin-off it just shows
you that the power of the fans that you
can get what you want thank you
supernatural for showing me
that kind of a family they call me um
biker barbie and supernatural
and they wrote in like mini golf and
supernatural and
in freaky they call me murder barbie and
there might be a little bit of golf and
freaky as well and so maybe they'll
start writing in poodles
that movie is so special i was the
biggest greta gerwig fan
also i'm a huge fan of cherisher ronin
and so just to be in the presence of
them
was a gift so greta would always have
everybody wearing name tags like the
first two weeks of filming so to get
everybody's names
but she also had everybody write down
their spirit animal and her and i were
both poodles
so obviously we're soul mates
me yeah i would love it if like millie
bobby brown played me in a movie but i
would also love to play millie bobby
brown in a movie can i just do a movie
with millie bobby brown
that would be cool thank you buzzfeed
for these awesome fan questions with my
dogs we've had so much fun
haven't we have you had a good time very
good and i hope that
you guys go watch freaky
[Music]
you